When I was a student here, I volunteered for
Recording for the Blind, which had its offices
over in the Princeton Seminary and I would
walk over there about twice a month.
They had me become a monitor rather than a
reader, because they decided that my voice
wasn't particularly good for conveying expression
in the reading.
So my job was mainly to watch as somebody
else read, and make sure they didn't drop
a word along the way.
After I left Princeton and started my profession
career, a lot of my service ended up being
of a different variety.
When somebody asked me to serve on a committee,
I would always agree.
I'd look for opportunities to do things like
serving on nonprofit boards or commissions,
and I think there's a connection between these
things that's important for all Princetonians
as they move into their careers.
And the question is all about asking, how
can I help and how can I contribute to my
community?
And that for me is why it's so important for
service to be a part of the student experience
here at Princeton.
I believe that Princetonians, as they move
on into the world, are going to contribute
and perform kinds of service in all sorts
of different vocations.
But I think it all starts with that question
about how can I help, and how can I make a
difference.
So for me, that's why "Princeton in the nation's
service" begins with the service that our
students do while they're here on campus.